MANDY WAITE: This person's
asking a question, What--
10 different definitions
of a Frontend
versus a Backend Instance?
And they're still not really
quite clear on what the
difference is between Frontends
and Backends.
Is that something you can
explain to everybody?
FRED SAURE: Yeah,
so we actually--
you mentioned this in the
introduction, sort of the two
different notions
of a Backend.
You talked about mobile Backends
for Cloud endpoints.
And then App Engine has a
specific definition of what a
Frontend is and what
a Backend is.
And frankly, other customers
have said, that's confusing.
And we found it a little bit
limiting in what developers
want to do with their
applications.
And so if you've been actually
reading through the release
notes, carefully, you'll notice
that we've already
started talking about kind of
a new way of classifying
components in an application
called Servers.
And what we're going to do is
we're going to get rid of the
two special cases.
The Frontends that do things one
way and the Backends who
do things slightly differently,
and we're just
going to say, you can have as
many different types of
Servers as you want.
You can call them Frontends
and Backends.
Maybe one of them is your mobile
API, and one is your
admin API, and a third one is
something experimental.
Maybe you have a component
that's text message
processing, and another
component that's like real
time interactive stuff, and a
third one that's reports.
Every application
is different.
But when you get beyond kind of
a trivial application, you
often want to logically split
your application into pieces.
You may want to deploy the
different pieces separately,
like your mobile Backend that's
handling all your
mobile requests, maybe have
a new version for that.
And this will allow you to see
separate traffic graphs for
each of your server versions.
Your logs will be
separated out.
So your mobile Backend logs and
your static image logs can
be separate.
So all of that's coming.
Just check out the release
notes, you'll see that.
And just sort of forgive
us for calling them
Frontends and Backends.
We'll make that go away.
You have an application, split
it in logical pieces, and
we'll allow you to configure the
different pieces the way
you want, whether you want
different instance sizes,
different logs, et cetera.
MANDY WAITE: So things like,
what a Frontend has currently,
autoscaling.
That will just be a property
of a server instance?
FRED SAURE: Exactly, so you
say, if I have a mobile
Backend how does scaling
[INAUDIBLE]?
I have this batch Backend where
I'm only going to do
certain administrative tasks,
I actually only want one
instance of the server running,
and it's just going
to be crawling some database or
doing some background work.
And you can have variations
in between.
So we're making it easier and
we're simplifying the
terminology.